[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I am very,
very happy to be hosting
one of the best chefs,
not only in Latin America,
but in the world.
She's a creative force.
She's a successful
entrepreneur, author,
and she's definitely
a passionate feminist.
So if you will welcome me in--
join me in welcoming Martha
Ortiz, Chef Martha Ortiz.
MARTHA ORTIZ:
[INAUDIBLE] thank you.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Well, Martha, thank
you very much for being here.
I'll start with just doing
a little bit of context.
I know that Martha is
incredibly successful.
She has a restaurant in
Mexico City that has twice
been named in the San Pellegrino
list of the World's 50 Best
Latin American Restaurants,
which is a great success.
It's the number one
Mexican restaurant
on the list, which is
a French counterpart.
And she's an author of eight
books, two in the works.
She's a known media personality.
She is currently the
judge in "Top Chef"--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
SPEAKER: --in Mexico.
MARTHA ORTIZ: The only woman.
SPEAKER: The only woman
in "Top Chef Mexico."
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
SPEAKER: And she recently
opened her latest
international venture here
in London, no other than 1
Park Lane, which is in
the Intercontinental
Hotel in Mayfair, which is
also a remarkable achievement.
"Master Chef," I
think, is shooting, no,
part of the [INAUDIBLE]?
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, we're
finished with that.
SPEAKER: You're
finished, "Master Chef."
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes,
we're finished.
SPEAKER: For this season.
So who is interested in the
series, you can check it out.
So this is going to be
a conversation, Martha.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of
course, thank you.
SPEAKER: We'd like to make it
as interactive as possible.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of
course, of course.
SPEAKER: And, well, first
of all, congratulations.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARTHA ORTIZ: Oh, thank
you for inviting me.
I am very happy.
I'm very pleased.
I think sometimes life
can be like a recipe.
SPEAKER: Yes.
MARTHA ORTIZ: So it's
important to share
the secrets so
everybody can know
how to handle the ingredients.
I think that some
people can make a master
recipe of their lives
and make something
unique and remarkable.
And I think like good cuisine,
good persons can be shared.
So I'm very happy to be here.
And let's talk about
the ingredients in life.
SPEAKER: Yes.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Let's
talk about what
is beautiful, what it's not.
And what do you do with this--
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
MARTHA ORTIZ: --in
the every day.
SPEAKER: So I think
what we thought
about is we wanted to
touch on, obviously,
Martha's journey, her
approach to her craft,
talk about resilience
and setbacks
and talk about venturing
into different projects.
And I want to start a little
bit from the beginning.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: What you
might not know is
that Martha has a degree
in political science.
So she focused her
studies in university
in political science.
So I wonder, Martha, what was
the origin and the impetus
to focus in that area?
And how did you move--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Move.
Or not move.
SPEAKER: --to gastronomy.
MARTHA ORTIZ: [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: How did you
find your calling?
MARTHA ORTIZ: You know, I
born in a very blessed home.
My mother is an artist.
My father is a medical doctor.
And when I was a little girl,
I remember that everything
happens in the table.
They invite the most interesting
people to have dinner with us,
to share the stories, to
share what they were doing.
So I remember that I saw sitting
kind of this Octavio Paz,
and he was a Nobel Prize.
So I went down to the
library and started
reading these beautiful
poems and see him eating.
So I start believing that
in tables, everything
could happen, agreement,
disagreement, and the food
has its ceremony.
So I think that--
that idea, when
you are a little girl, it plants
like a seed in your brain.
Then I grew up, and I remember
that I said to my father
that he was very strict, as
all the surgeons, you know?
My father preformed the
first kidney transplant
in Mexico and Latin America.
And I'm named Martha because
of his first patient.
Then he married
Martha, my mother.
So it was a beautiful story,
but he was very strict.
You can imagine a surgeon.
So I remember that I said to my
father, I want to be a curator.
My father's, a curator?
You want to work in a museum?
And I said, yes, I will
adore to work in a museum.
I think it's wonderful.
And I remember that he
told me, OK, you are 14.
You can go out, work,
put the money together,
and go to study to be a curator.
And then I decide that I have
to go to a very good school
to have a formal education
because my father always--
and I have to say
it and honor him.
He always believed in
intelligence more than having
boys or girls.
We were two girls.
And I have another
sister and a brother,
and he never make a
difference in that way.
So he said me, go
to a good school.
So I decided-- and
I read the careers,
and they were accounting,
my god, math, no, you know?
Economy, and I say,
mmm, political science.
And I thought it was
very interesting.
I really like it.
I went to ITAM.
It's a very school--
a very good one.
We were like, at the
beginning, maybe three girls
and like 20 boys.
The three girls finished
and just three boys.
So we-- we-- and you
know at the same time.
And at the end of this
career, they ask us to make--
in Mexico, you have
to make a thesis.
SPEAKER: Yeah, a presentation.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, yes,
to have your career done.
And they asked us to make a
study about social mobility
and party votes.
It was very interesting.
So I went to a community that is
called Milpa Alta near Mexico.
And you have to go to the home
and say, hello, good afternoon.
I come from the ITAM.
I want to ask you, how
many children do you have?
And they say to you, 10.
OK.
How many bedrooms?
Just this one, you know?
I start feeling very bad,
because in Mexico, sometimes,
I was talking
about the contrast,
that it's a country
with a lot of contrast.
But every time that
I went to a home,
I remember that they
offered me mole.
You know, in Milpa Alta,
it's the place where we have
a lot of cactus fruit and mole.
And I remember that these people
that has no protein, and this
is a true story, they
serve us in peltre.
Peltre is like an enamel,
or how do you say it?
It's [SPEAKING SPANISH]
enamel, no?
Like--
SPEAKER: Yeah, metal--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Metal,
but it's painted.
And it's painted
with blue and white.
So in that moment,
I realized that they
were richer than me
eating in the cosmos
because everything was
blue and with the stars.
So I came with this idea,
you know, with my mentor.
And I say, I want to change.
And I want to build a story
about food and identity
in this community because I
think it's very important.
It's through women who are
sharing these kind of recipes
through the other young women.
So I think it's
quite interesting
to talk with these people about
this richness of ingredients
and the point of view.
And I started looking that
they didn't have any--
how can they say it?
This kind of food that comes
to big chains in Milpa Alta you
never see, or a McDonald's,
or a Burger King.
There is no chains.
It's just a community.
And why?
Because they have a
religious party every day.
And they make it with food.
So for me, it was fantastic
seeing that it's a--
you know, it was
the Day of the Dead,
and they shared this food.
Then was the Posadas, they
shared all the Posadas.
So food became part of that
religious and nice identity.
So I finish, and they
say, this is fantastic.
I really like.
But I like this part of
food, the academic part,
when I started building this
kind of Mexican sense, no,
the strong, the passion,
the woman, the fire,
the witchcraft.
And I remember that I
finished that story,
and they really love it in ITAM.
Because I finish
saying that for me,
this kind of traditional
cooks in Mexico,
they're like,
[SPEAKING SPANISH]..
SPEAKER: Witchcraft.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Witchcraft woman,
that with four ingredients,
they can build everything.
So we are friends.
I still adore them.
I adore all the
traditional cooks
because they're kind
of anonymous heroines.
Every day, they--
most of them, they
don't have husbands because
they left to the States to work.
SPEAKER: Yes, as immigrants.
MARTHA ORTIZ: They emigrate
in very difficult conditions.
And sometimes, they
never came back,
and they take care
about the family selling
food in the markets.
And I think that makes another
kind of economy, but beautiful.
So I remember the tables,
these ladies, and I said,
I need to build my own place,
but I didn't have the money.
I didn't have the
money in that moment.
So I have been very
blessed because then there
was a group of women who
were very kind with me
and invited me to make dinners
with them because Mexico was
on trend because, you
know, it was starting
after Carlos Salinas de
Gortari-- this big moment
with everything, you know?
Mexico [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: That moment in which
the country was privatizing.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes,
privatizing, it was very--
SPEAKER: A lot of
the [INAUDIBLE]..
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
So we were on the news.
We were everywhere.
So they invited me to help
them with the dinners.
And I really adore--
and every time that we
went to make a dinner,
I'd ask the main
chef, can I stay here
for maybe three months?
And they say, yes, if you
want to make tortillas or make
the coffee, it will be great.
So I was a helper.
I served coffees.
And I was very happy, you
know, I learned a lot.
Then I returned to Mexico.
I built this consulting
office with the husband of one
of my friends.
I always had been
very close to the art
scene with the husband of
Mariana Cuevas, the daughter
of Jose Luis Cuevas, this very
famous artist in Mexico that
just passed away, and
my business partner
passed away too very young.
But I adored to start creating
restaurant concepts with him
and making these
great events, and food
started being my identity too.
SPEAKER: So let's
talk about that.
MARTHA ORTIZ: And then
I saw like "Like Water
for Chocolate," this
is a true story.
SPEAKER: Ahh, the more.
MARTHA ORTIZ: I read the
book, and I saw the movie,
and I said, I want
to be like Tita.
I want to be a rebel.
I don't want to
marry the man that I
have to marry in these
kind of bourgeoisie thing.
I want to be like her.
I want to be a rebel.
And we adored that movie.
SPEAKER: It's fantastic.
If you haven't seen it like--
MARTHA ORTIZ: I read the book.
I think it's the most celebrated
Spanish book, you know--
SPEAKER: "Like Water
for Chocolate."
MARTHA ORTIZ: "Like
Water for Chocolate."
Now, I'm very good friends of
Laura Esquivel because once,
I--
the [INAUDIBLE]
made this book that
is called "Gritos y Sussuros."
And I was beside her, and
I said, you don't know,
but I am what I am because
of you, and she was, why?
Because you built the
character in a woman
that was a rebel through food.
So in the movie,
what is beautiful is
if she was in love, everybody
was in love with the food.
So I started believing that
food can have emotions.
And if you're sad, everybody
is sad when it takes the food.
So feelings can
trespass the food.
So everything has started
melting, you know?
Everything at the same time.
And then Emanuele, my partner,
decide to go back to Paris
because he was French.
And I said, what I'm going
to do with this office?
I don't like to
charge the clients.
I don't like that
kind of things.
I love the creative part.
So I remember that I married
an artist, my first marriage.
I married a very
rebel artist that
was handsome, and nice, and--
SPEAKER: Perfect.
MARTHA ORTIZ: The
perfect fit, you know?
But in the moment that I told
him, I want to do something.
he was very, very clear with me.
Yes, you're going
to work for me.
That's what you're going to do.
And he gave me a book
that it was called,
"The Wife of the
Artist," and it was
horrible because all the wives,
they have miserable lives,
you know, miserable lives,
just some examples like
[INAUDIBLE] maybe that you have,
you know, the little thing.
But they were horrible
lives, and I said,
I don't want this life.
So I remember that I
went out of that house
with just like 10 pesos,
no car, no nothing.
SPEAKER: $0.30 today.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes,
I remember that.
I remember perfectly.
And I went with
my mother's house,
and I said, I have to
be here, I'm sorry,
maybe three, four months, but
I will go away another time.
And she told me,
yes, of course, you
can be here three
or four months.
SPEAKER: Fantastic.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Fantastic.
That's a true story.
SPEAKER: It seems
that you talk of,
you know, gastronomy like
almost as a language.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: And I have seen
some of your interviews
that you like to tell that
you're a writer in flavors.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course, I
think that's the storytelling.
SPEAKER: In your style,
I'd like delve a little bit
in your style.
Artists usually say that part of
being a great artist is to find
and inhabit your own style.
Marcus Samuelsson recently said
that part of being a great chef
is to knowing who you are.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: So your style
is very unique, you know,
from what you read in the
press, it's very bold.
It's very feminine.
It's very creative, but I think
it would be great for everybody
to hear it from you, like--
MARTHA ORTIZ: What is my style?
SPEAKER: How would
you describe it?
How would you-- and how
have you developed it?
How have you come to
find this is Martha?
MARTHA ORTIZ: The first
thing is that I never
ever want to copy no one.
The other thing that I adore
is showing that I'm a woman.
I don't want-- I think there
is in the world, right now,
you know, the big chefs, they
have this minimalistic style,
very masculine.
And I say, I don't--
I'm not-- I don't feel OK to
copy these and transport it
to a dish.
I adore these kind of
baroque, Mexican beauty.
So and even I--
I was talking this morning with
a very nice girl that I said,
I remember when I see all
the pseudorealistic painters
and artists that live in Mexico,
like woman in Wonderland,
you know Frida, Remedios
Varo, and Leonora Carrington,
this great photographer,
[INAUDIBLE],, the one
with the big curls you know?
And I said, this is fantastic.
I want to be like them.
They were my role models.
I never said I want to be
like the Joel Robuchon.
I want to be like this artist
because they find the way.
Imagine Frida because
everybody now sees Frida.
She suffers a lot, everybody--
but finding her style being
married with one of the most
important artists in the world
at the--
he painted this big
murals, and she decided
to make these small paintings.
And she was-- and that paintings
were her mural, you know?
She invented herself
like that's--
that's what the exhibition said.
And when you go to
Casa Azul of Frida,
you really start feeling that
she invented the way that she
wanted to be, but not
because of Diego, because
of her own [INAUDIBLE] with her.
She used to adore animals.
So she put the animals here.
She adored to have, you
know, her big eyebrows,
and she never pulled it out.
She put her-- her, you
know, the beautiful,
red nails and with the rings.
And his grand niece is a friend
of mine, Guillermo Kahlo,
the photographer, he
always told me then
when Frida went out on
the street, people laughed
about her, imagining that--
SPEAKER: Yeah, like
the appearance--
MARTHA ORTIZ:
--bourgeoisie society
in Mexico in that
moment, looking
this woman going with
ribbons on the hair, strong.
And she couldn't walk
very well because she
had polio when she was--
SPEAKER: Yeah, she
had-- and an accident.
MARTHA ORTIZ: And an
accident called polio.
She wanted, you
know-- and I said,
these women are fantastic.
I want to be a
woman in Wonderland,
in my own Wonderland.
So it was more personal.
And I developed-- and
I never want to see it,
I say, this is in fashion.
This is in trend.
This is made by this male chef.
And I said, no, I--
I'm a woman.
I love lyrics.
I love colors.
I'm a proud Mexican,
and I'm trying
to build a business with
a lot of women involved.
I give the same opportunities
and sometimes a little bit more
to the woman to
tell you the truth.
If I have a man producer,
a woman producer,
I say, let's see, bring
her first, you know?
Because for them,
it's very difficult.
Imagine a lady who sells
tomatoes in Mexico.
It's very difficult to get to
a restaurant, to be a producer.
So I have to be caring
about these type of things.
I think so.
SPEAKER: And for everybody
to know, I think,
there's a fantastic interview
from Martha with the "Evening
Standard" in which she's--
you're credited with
saying you want to break--
MARTHA ORTIZ: The caramel
ceiling, of course.
SPEAKER: --the caramel ceiling.
You want to help other women
to break the caramel ceiling.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course,
I say the caramel
because it's not the
glass ceiling for me.
It's the caramel ceiling.
SPEAKER: I think it's
a great topic on that.
And I would like to hear
your thoughts on how--
what does that mean for
you in your industry?
MARTHA ORTIZ: These kind
of things-- you know,
first I hate when they said--
and I'm very, you know, in the
opinion of Dominique Crenn,
this great chef--
it's horrible that
they say, this prize
goes for the woman chef.
I think that's horrible.
It's not the best woman chef.
It's the best chef.
You don't have to
say it that way.
You don't have to say it--
let's make them happy.
Let's say the best woman chef.
I don't think that's fair.
It's the best chef of the world.
SPEAKER: True.
MARTHA ORTIZ: And I think
if they start dividing,
that's not nice.
What I'm trying to do is
really to build opportunities
because maybe in Mexico--
here it's different, maybe.
But in Mexico, when
you have trainees,
I try to educate and
be mentor of women
and say, I have these 10 men.
I have these six women.
Let's bring the women
first because they
want to have an opportunity.
They won't have it
maybe in other places.
Or they will be very small
windows or doors to open.
So I'm trying.
My pastry chef is a woman.
SPEAKER: Which is
fantastic, [INAUDIBLE]..
MARTHA ORTIZ: I have one
sous chef man, one woman,
and my head chef is a woman.
And I'm trying, you know,
even with the flowers,
I buy it from a woman.
So I'm trying to make this
network that everything
is, you know, very feminine.
And because we don't have
opportunities in [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER: Do you
find that more chefs
are following your example?
Do you see somebody--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, I
think they're-- they're--
SPEAKER: --or do you
find yourself alone.
MARTHA ORTIZ: There's
a wonderful woman chef
that I adore.
She's young.
She's from Tabasco.
Now she has a
restaurant in Mexico.
And she always
called me, I'm making
this name because of you.
Can you help me?
And I say, yes, of course,
because I put names
to the dish that's different.
I won't say, creme caramel with
the perfume of da, da, da, no.
No.
I call it Mary goes
to the flower shop
because Mary is a character.
And she changes every month.
Even Mary has been
candidate and has lost.
Sometimes she is fat, and she
doesn't want to be in the menu.
You know?
SPEAKER: She has her temper.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yeah,
she has a temper.
She's a modern woman.
She goes to the library.
She wants to make a PhD.
She's a modern woman, you know?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MARTHA ORTIZ: She's getting
divorced, so, please, you know,
Mary has to take care of her.
She's with the attorney.
And everybody laughed.
Now I'm making that book.
I have, I think, like,
14 emails from my editor
because he's mad because I
have to do it more quickly.
But this is a fantastic book
because the name is Maria,
because I love the name
in Spanish, "Marie Va, "
"Maria is Moving," "Recipes
for a Woman with Greatness."
SPEAKER: Oh, I love that.
I love that.
MARTHA ORTIZ: So what I'm doing
is putting this-- it's not just
like a gastronomy book.
The first part is
talking about what
ingredients you need in life.
And the second part of the book
are my favorite women in Mexico
that they tell the
recipe of their own life.
So it's fantastic to see a
woman like Carmen Aristegui
with a big knife and say, I
have to cut everybody, you know?
And she gives a recipe
of little cookies.
So it's this kind
of high contrast.
So--
SPEAKER: It sounds like a
fantastic project, Martha.
MARTHA ORTIZ: It's going to be--
it's going to be the project.
SPEAKER: You're more than
welcome to come back again.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, of course.
SPEAKER: It will be a
privlege to have that.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, and
we need to bring these 12
women that they are fantastic.
You know them.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
MARTHA ORTIZ: And some,
they are, you know,
very famous and the other
are not famous, but for me,
are heroines.
They are in the resistance.
They make things
for the Mexicans.
Maybe they're not well known,
but they are fantastic.
SPEAKER: Yeah, and you touched
on something very interesting
now, which is the struggle, no?
There's a lot of determination.
There's a lot of
resilience that needs
to come when you
are basically trying
to change the status quo.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: There's
one anecdote that I
would like to share with the
audience that illustrates
very well your nature and
your spirit of resilience
and struggle.
So in 2003, Martha opened
her first restaurant.
Immediately, it was a success,
very well known, very popular.
MARTHA ORTIZ: I worked so much.
You cannot imagine.
I was the valet parking,
the security, the cook.
I went to a bank.
I remember my husband told me,
you will never get the money.
So I went to a bank.
I remember that I
bought something
that I couldn't bought, and
I returned it the other day
after the bank appointment.
I remember that I
went very elegant.
And I asked the man,
I need $1 million.
And he told me, for what?
And I said, for a restaurant.
And they gave it to me.
SPEAKER: Wow!
Fantastic.
MARTHA ORTIZ: I said, here's my
business plan, and I show it,
you know?
And they give me
a million dollars.
This is a true story.
SPEAKER: That is a
fantastic story--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
SPEAKER: --I think.
MARTHA ORTIZ: And I returned
it with a lot of people
because I couldn't afford it.
I need the $1 million
to build the restaurant,
and it was a great success.
SPEAKER: It was a fantastic
success, like, it took off.
However, five years
later, the government--
MARTHA ORTIZ: I
changed the location.
SPEAKER: --asked you.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, remember
that I have these beautiful--
but I need to make it--
a lot of people was
in saying to me,
Martha we need to build
this restaurant in Spain,
and New York, and everything.
And the space was very
beautiful, but I said,
I need a private room.
I need an office in the house.
I need to build it.
So I saw the most beautiful,
beautiful corner in Mexico
where Louis Vuitton
was, and I say,
OK, Louis Vuitton, let's go.
You will be Louis Vuitton.
I will be Aguila y Sol, a
Mexican brand and a woman
brand.
So I changed location.
SPEAKER: You changed
location, and then--
MARTHA ORTIZ: A beautiful
place, Legoretta made that.
SPEAKER: Legorreta.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Made
this space that was--
SPEAKER: Fantastic art.
MARTHA ORTIZ:
Beautiful, fantastic.
And we have a serpent
on the ceilings
because I don't build
restaurants with architects.
I always ask artists,
you know, people
who like opera, or woman
designers, for everything.
I love that people
from different--
not just the common
people, no, people
that is a little bit crazy.
SPEAKER: And they--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes,
a little talent.
SPEAKER: The spiky ones.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes,
the spiky ones.
I adore that.
SPEAKER: So the
government asked Martha
to shut down the restaurant.
MARTHA ORTIZ: They
closed me, my restaurant.
SPEAKER: So they asked
her with the excuse
that you were short
one parking space.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Less
than one parking space.
SPEAKER: Less than
one parking space.
MARTHA ORTIZ: I
remember that afternoon,
and every time I remember, I
cry because it was so horrible.
Because people was having lunch.
They came in, and
they say, we're
going to close this restaurant.
And I say, why?
Because you need to less
than one parking space.
So I remember that afternoon--
SPEAKER: I'm sure that it
must have been devastating.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Devastating.
They took the people away.
They took my people away.
And at the end, I didn't
want to go, they--
they said to me, we would
leave you here, and I said,
it's perfect.
I will die in here.
I have food.
I have water.
I can be here six months.
SPEAKER: And I know how to.
MARTHA ORTIZ: And I
will make my resistance.
I will call the newspapers.
And they took me
outside by the force.
SPEAKER: And what do you
think the motivation was?
MARTHA ORTIZ: I
think I was punished.
SPEAKER: Because of how
successful you were?
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of my success,
of course, and I was a woman,
and I was very young.
And I cannot tell you it was
this person or this person.
It was a system because
at the same time,
a lot of women struggled.
Carmen Arestegui lost her job.
A lot of women [INAUDIBLE]
it was, for me, devastating.
SPEAKER: It was a--
there was a period
of a clampdown
on certain local personalities.
MARTHA ORTIZ: I lost everything
in three days, my work,
my house, everything.
SPEAKER: But fast forward
one year, and in one year--
MARTHA ORTIZ: I remember
that I was crying,
and a friend of mine--
this is another true story
how women can help other women.
She's a very influential
and intelligent lady,
Denise Dresser.
SPEAKER: Yeah, of
course, a journalist--
MARTHA ORTIZ: A journalist in
Mexico and in "The New York
Times" and a very good friend.
I remember that I was crying,
crying, crying, crying, crying,
and she came to my house.
She's very small, not very
thin, what are you crying about?
And I said, I lost
everything, everything.
I lose my restaurant.
I lose my money.
I lose everything that
I have worked for.
And she looked me in the
eyes, and she told me,
you haven't lost anything.
You have it here.
So let's go.
She offered me the door,
and she took me away.
So I remember I was
crying in the street.
I have to find a horrible work
to survive, that's the truth.
I review menus, now casting,
the things that I don't like,
but I have to do it.
And I learned how
can you be punished.
SPEAKER: And that's
what I would like
for you to share in
retrospective because one
year after Martha opened her
current restaurant, which
is the one that catapulted
you to international acclaim,
but I think that a lot of us
will or have faced setbacks.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: Now in
retrospective, what do you
think made you
find your strength
and just bounce back
with all that force?
MARTHA ORTIZ: I saw that I
have a social responsibility
and to be an example
for other women.
I don't do it just for myself.
I remember to see my cooks,
chef, what are we going to do?
We don't have work.
And I say, we will find a work.
Don't worry.
And I remember that that's
why the name is Dulce Patria.
People doesn't know,
that's my private joke
because I think that my homeland
is sweeter than my government.
SPEAKER: Yes, dulce patria
means sweet homeland.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, it's my--
it's my private joke.
And-- and the logo, it's
a woman with a flame
like an Amazon and a horse.
So if they do it again,
I will do it again.
I told them, if you're going to
close me the restaurant again,
I will open again, and we will
die maybe first you or me,
but we will keep like this, no?
You close.
I will open.
You close me, I will open.
And [INAUDIBLE].
So I felt in that
moment, that I have
to get a story not just
for me because I have to be
an example for a lot of women.
I was in the supermarket,
and they come crying with me.
I cannot believe this, chef.
We are very sorry.
What are you going to do?
And I said, we have
to do it together.
We're going to build it again.
So I make Dulce Patria.
I don't know which--
now I see it back.
If it happened to me, I
don't know, but I say,
I have to do it.
I divorced the twice.
Imagine my husband was working
with the current president,
and I say I cannot
sit with these people.
I must go.
SPEAKER: Of course.
MARTHA ORTIZ: I cannot
be in the same table.
I have another idea of life.
I have values.
So go for your work.
I will stay here.
SPEAKER: And congratulations,
you have actually stayed.
MARTHA ORTIZ: But it was hard.
SPEAKER: And stayed
for the long time.
MARTHA ORTIZ: It was hard.
I remember the bills.
Oh!
Is this what I'm
going to do, you know?
Oh, my god.
But you find the strength.
You find the strength.
SPEAKER: And now, Martha, with
your most recent venture--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
SPEAKER: --here.
The name is Ella Canta,
which means, She Sings.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: And I'll led
you to the story of of--
MARTHA ORTIZ: We
all sing together.
SPEAKER: --of the name.
But I think it's
very, very interesting
that you're coming to one of
the most competitive markets
the UK, gastronomy.
We find that in
our jobs at Google,
we need to venture
elsewhere, and we often
struggle, no, on how to
adapt to that new market.
And you have that
added complexity
that you have said that
you want to bring and stay
as authentic as possible.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: How do you
balance that objective
of being-- like
remaining as authentic
as possible with probably
the needs or the pressure
to adapt to the local
taste or the local market?
MARTHA ORTIZ: I think London
is very international,
and people is used to
have this big palate.
And talking about
big palate, you
have great Indian restaurants,
great Asian restaurants.
So I think people
is open to flavors.
That's the first thing.
Second, I think that Mexican
cuisine is very powerful.
And I think it's very sensual.
So I'm sure that it
will seduce everybody
because when you try a mole,
you're trying 50 ingredients.
And I'm sure, and that's
part of Maria of the book,
the nuns made that
recipe, and I think
they made that
recipe because they
weren't allowed to get married.
So all the sensualness,
all the young--
they come through food.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes,
yes, so you try that,
and you feeling in ecstasy
when it's well done, really.
Oh, how you try, and
these 50 ingredients
melt in your mouth, the
chocolate, the spices,
the cinnamon.
Everything is so
powerful, and I'm
sure that that's why Mexican
food is on trend because it's
the Old and the
New World together.
SPEAKER: Such a great
fusion, you know?
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, we're not
inventing fusion between China
and France, you know?
Mexican food in the
conception is fusion food.
We have these very
interesting pre-Hispanic era
touch that it's true.
[? The sun ?] emperor has
these 300 dishes every day.
And they were-- he
can choose from,
because he was thin, remember?
SPEAKER: He was.
MARTHA ORTIZ: People said,
maybe it was like this.
No, he needed to choose.
They were warriors.
They need to make a strong.
And then the Spanish came
with all the Arabic influence.
So I think it melted perfectly.
And then in all the convents
in the Baroque time,
they rebuild, and they
make this Mexican identity,
like the mole, like
the pipian like--
SPEAKER: It's like twice it
has been like [INAUDIBLE]..
MARTHA ORTIZ: Like
all these sauces.
And I have an idea
of, at the beginning--
and I always said that when
Hernan Cortes came to Mexico
or La Nueva Espana in that
moment that they called it,
and he saw La Malinche--
Malinche was this beautiful
and wonderful lady
that everybody
looks as a traitor
because she was
very intelligent.
But she wasn't a traitor.
She was the mother
of Mexico in a way.
When he tries her, he adored her
because it tastes like the sun,
salty.
Have you tried?
Have you put your hand in
the sun and then tried?
It's a little bit salty.
So I think he get in love
because she was salty
because she tasted like the sun.
And I have that idea that
this melting, wonderful parts
all over the world that
they were in Mexico.
That's why Mexican
gastronomy is so rich.
That's why our
culture is so rich.
That's why we have the artists
that we have, the movie
directors right now.
They are amazing, why?
Because we have this imagination
and this idea of beauty.
Before I come to London, I saw
"Roma," the new film of Cuaron.
SPEAKER: Cuaron.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Wow!
An amazing story-- what a
profound story about these--
this Mexico--
SPEAKER: And so proud--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of
what they are doing.
SPEAKER: The work
they are doing.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
But they have this imagination,
and that imagination
is through food too.
SPEAKER: I wouldn't like
to hijack your time.
So I want to have the--
I'll give the
opportunity, anybody to--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: --ask any question or--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course, and
thank you for being here.
SPEAKER: --share anything that
you would like to ask Martha?
If not, I'll carry on.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I went to your
country a few months ago,
and I had the Maria
from Mexico dessert.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It was
actually one of the best
desserts I've ever had.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: But you were
saying how it changes,
and sometimes it's
not on the menu.
Is it always the same,
the actual dessert,
or does the dessert
itself change?
MARTHA ORTIZ: In Mexico,
we change it every month.
And here, we change
it every time
that we have on a special menu.
Now Maria is this new one.
Maria went to Mictlan.
Mictlan is the land of the
dead for the Aztecs here.
But in Mexico, she
goes all the way.
She went there.
She returned with victory.
She is alive.
And, now, she makes a
government of all the stars.
So she creates an
eclipse in Mexico.
So everybody says,
she's powerful.
And I say, of course, yes.
She can government
even the stars.
SPEAKER: That's incredible.
So when-- when do
have the [INAUDIBLE]??
MARTHA ORTIZ: This one--
Maria, Maria by Mictlan--
SPEAKER: It's currently.
MARTHA ORTIZ: It's currently.
In Mexico, she [INAUDIBLE].
SPEAKER: OK.
MARTHA ORTIZ: I have
more hands [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: OK, so if I go back,
I can't have the same dessert.
MARTHA ORTIZ: You
want the same one?
AUDIENCE: The same dessert.
MARTHA ORTIZ: You want
Mary Comes to London?
AUDIENCE: It was the--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Just ask
us in the reservation.
You have the right people.
Stephen will make it happen.
He will tell the kitchen.
Or Gabriella will
say to Elliott,
no problem, no problem.
Thank you very much.
And I'm very pleased
that you liked Maria.
Maria is a character.
It's not a dessert.
It's like she's a writer.
She's everything.
AUDIENCE: Why did you decide
to open a restaurant in London?
MARTHA ORTIZ: London?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
maybe you said it, sorry.
MARTHA ORTIZ: I think it's--
no, I didn't say it.
I adore London since
I was a little girl.
I remember that I came here
with my parents, and I really
I adored it because
it was the first time
that I tried Indian food and
these kind of new flavors.
So as I said, all
the seeds stay here.
Then the group that
I'm working with,
they went to Mexico,
see different chefs,
and they decided that I could
be successful in London maybe
because I have, I think,
this imagination ingredient
that I adore.
So it was built
in the both ways.
SPEAKER: And I think I will
exhort everybody to go--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Because
it can taste nice.
SPEAKER: Because
it is quite unique.
I think it is beyond what
you would usually think of--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of course.
SPEAKER: --in Mexican cuisine.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, of course.
SPEAKER: It is
remarkably different
and incredibly authentic.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Thank you.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: So I definitely
encourage you to try.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that you're working now
on a new book with
a different concept
really empowering a
certain number of women
and their story.
What about your previous books?
Were they also--
MARTHA ORTIZ: No, they
are are not cookbooks.
I'm making these
because I think I
have to share my experience of
Aguila y Sol that was terrible
in a way, but in
a positive part.
And I think because I make
so much of this effort,
and I was telling
you that I believe
that life can be
like your recipe,
building these ingredients,
that I have to share it.
And I would love not to be just
the only one that shared it.
So I'm asking people that I
highly respect in Mexico that
have been through difficult
times, maybe worse than mine,
but they make--
they're my kind of
heroines, you know?
I believe in the power of woman.
I said, I like Wonder Woman,
you know, this kind of Wonder
Womans that we have in Mexico.
Sometimes I say, this
woman has lost a child.
They are here to
ask for justice,
and that's the
work of every day.
That's very-- that's hard.
That's hard.
AUDIENCE: How long
does it actually
take to train all the
chefs in the restaurant
before they actually bring
on the plate what you expect?
And are you actually
cooking yourself sometimes?
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, of
course, [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: But here
in London, like--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yeah,
sometimes, yes, of course.
AUDIENCE: So when
are you there again?
When can we go?
MARTHA ORTIZ: I'm--
OK.
I'm coming back in February.
I'm opening a new restaurant
in Mexico, very interesting,
because it's a cafe.
And I think we are
losing all the bread
Mexican tradition
that I adore, even
the names we call it,
cocoles, purequitas, conchas,
and novias.
You know, all these
beautiful names.
So I'm opening a cafe with
all the traditional bread--
SPEAKER: Oh, wow!
MARTHA ORTIZ: --with
pulque, with chochitos,
with all these kind of beauties.
I'm going to open it in January.
I think after Aguila y Sol, I
was a little bit frightened,
you know, to--
I think it was unconscious.
So I stay in my small
castle, you know,
you put like a barrier,
but I decide last year
that I want to achieve
better things than I have.
And I start--
I'm going to open three
restaurants next year.
And, one, it's
going to be amazing,
because it's a theater.
It's not a restaurant.
We will have a place.
And the place will go
through [INAUDIBLE]..
And the menu is
going to be built
with one like Laura Esquivel,
"Like Water to Chocolate."
So we're going to
build this menu.
We're going to-- it's going
to be like a testing menu,
but even the things that
you're going to eat with
is not going to be conventional.
It's going to be
very interesting.
AUDIENCE: You're a
foreigner, and you're
a woman in a city that
is a very tough city.
What has been your biggest
challenge because I--
even, like, here the
chefs that we hear from,
there's hardly a lot of--
hardly any women
in your world, so
has that been challenging here?
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes, of course.
I think the most difficult
thing here for me is that I'm--
not all the time.
That's the first thing that if
I want to achieve something,
I maybe would need
to have more time,
you know, educating
people about Mexico
because I think one
of the challenges
is that people get confused
with Tex-Mex food and Mexican
and more right now, you know?
And what I believe for
me that it's a challenge,
sometimes, it's even--
hello, Martha.
No, it's hello, chef.
It's different, no?
So I think it's a way of--
of I was saying in
Mexico, they call
me chef because they
see me every day,
and they know that I have
control of everything,
of the fire, of the
fireman, of everything,
but here, I do the menu.
I work with great people.
But I don't have
the time, you know?
And that's difficult
for me sometimes.
So I have to create--
what I want to do
the next time is
make the chefs come
to Mexico and maybe
have more environment
of what we are doing.
I'm making this
dish of this blue
because I adore this painting
of Remedios Varo in this museum.
So we're going to take
this woman in Wonderland
in this plate and do it right.
That's what I'm going to
do, coming and going, not
just coming.
I think they have
to have, you know,
the blood, the spirit of Mexico.
SPEAKER: Do you
think that that is--
particularly like
the educating part,
how do you approach it
beyond your restaurant.
Obviously, the
restaurant is there.
And there's the food.
How-- how is--
MARTHA ORTIZ: In Mexico, I
do it completely different.
Sometimes, Mexico,
the chefs, they maybe
didn't have a formal education.
So on Sundays, we give them
Mexican history lessons.
SPEAKER: Oh, great.
MARTHA ORTIZ: So they feel
proud about what we are.
I invite very interesting
people, sometimes artists,
so they will know that we have
these figurative tradition
in Mexico.
And now we're going to have--
I think that is
going to be amazing,
because I love flowers.
But I don't like flowers
just because they are nice.
I adore them because they
have, I think, a spirit.
And in Mexico in the shamans
and in traditional medicine,
they use it to cure you.
So we're going to invite
an expert in flowers
and the shaman culture to
show us to make powders
and colors with the flowers.
So it's going to be amazing.
SPEAKER: That's something
you really use use, no?
Currently like flowers
is left and right which--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yeah,
and I adore it.
SPEAKER: --is a core part of it.
MARTHA ORTIZ: But I want to
use it more, but more as not
just as [INAUDIBLE].
I want the power of
these ingredients because
of the color, because
of the well being,
and because the
tradition, even, in
Mexican traditional medicine.
AUDIENCE: So we've touched
on this a little bit
before where we were
talking about how
your style is very
different from what
most chefs are doing nowadays.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Most chefs, as you
said, are very minimalist,
and you really celebrate
femininity in your food.
It's like very bold.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Exuberant.
Exuberant.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I remember
when I went to your restaurant
in Mexico City, you served these
incredible pineapple chips that
were in the shapes
of butterflies
and had edible glitter
on top of them.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Of
course, I adore it.
AUDIENCE: Which I thought--
I just-- as soon
as you served it,
I thought this is so badass and
so bold of this woman in such
a male-dominated field to be
saying, eat butterflies, like,
this is who I am.
MARTHA ORTIZ: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And I
wonder in your career
how much pushback did you get
because very often if you're
doing something different,
people tell you, don't do that.
That's wrong.
MARTHA ORTIZ: A lot.
AUDIENCE: And how did you come--
MARTHA ORTIZ: And I pay the
price, but I don't care.
AUDIENCE: How did you
come to decide that,
and how did you come to
never doubt yourself?
Because there's this
tricky trade off,
I think, sometimes between
being self-confident and not
listening to feedback.
So how did you
make sure that you
were finding the right path?
MARTHA ORTIZ: I always listen
to feedback about the flavors
because you need to
know, and people maybe
say, I don't like this, because
it has this taste, this, this.
But about the style, I
never asked to other cooks.
I go with the artist.
I remember that I built
this beautiful relation
with Ricardo Legorreta.
And I remember that I go
running to his house, I show,
do you like it?
And he told me-- he was the
best architect in Mexico
and say, no.
So I'd get back to
the kitchen and build
the salad in another way.
Do you like it?
No.
So I rem-- because I love
to hear from other artists.
Sometimes I invite
Guillermo Kahlo, that
is this great Mexican
photographer, and I say,
do you think these
has this power
and this beauty of Mexico?
Yes, Martha, but
think in this way.
So I always love to hear
that from another artist
more than another cook because
I think it's, as you said,
it's a temptation to be
like another person and more
in this global world.
And I think you need
to listen, and I go--
and I never go to another
restaurant to have inspiration.
I love to go to museums.
I can be-- today I saw
that it was [INAUDIBLE]
in the National--
in the Royal Academy.
And I love the gold and the
purple of [INAUDIBLE] together.
I want to see that because I--
and then I can go to Alexander
McQueen and say this is black,
and she's a woman--
she's a woman designer and say,
oh, Simone Rocha is putting,
you know, flowers,
all over the--
in her Instagram.
I love that kind of inspiration,
and when I make the black menu
that I'm taking
to San Francisco,
I read Cesar Vallejo,
this poet that I adore,
that said so much love.
but nothing against death.
And I start on that point.
So I get inspired by
that kind of things.
I can go to a
museum, and I start
crying because I think it's
too beautiful, you know?
People look at me like this.
But I cry because I think
it's overwhelming, you know?
I think where is
the beauty, I think
that when a person can create
beauty or more than that,
I think that our
lives have value
when you can share beauty.
And beauty can be
defined a lot of things,
but beauty can be in love,
in power, in paintings.
But I think that's our mission
in life to share beauty.
SPEAKER: Wow.
I'm inspired now, Martha.
MARTHA ORTIZ: That's what
I think in my small world.
And at the same time, we
didn't talk about that.
But I love to make
very healthy business
because then I can decide.
So now that I'm
making this cafe,
I want that this cafe be very
strong, financially talking,
so I can make decisions.
And I want to bring every
month [SPEAKING SPANISH]..
We call it like that in Mexico.
I don't know how to call it
here because they're not chefs.
SPEAKER: The master
bread maker, like--
MARTHA ORTIZ:
Master bread maker.
And I want that they can stay
in Mexico City for a month
and rent a very
nice home for them,
and share what they
have to share with us,
and give them all the respect.
So I need to find a
lot of money and make
it very healthy to do that.
So that's my point of view,
to make very strong business,
and if people doesn't like the
menu because of the glitter,
I don't care if
I think it's good
if I think that the people who
I really respect it's good.
I love to hear--
as you said, you
have to hear what
people say about the flavors.
But I don't want to
be like any male chef.
I adore being a woman.
I adore being a Mexican.
I'm a very proud Mexican.
And I remember that when
my grandfather gave me
these beautiful Filigrana
earrings with two drops.
And he told me,
and I believe him,
you are a princess
from Monte Alban.
And I believe it.
And I remember that all my
friends want to be, you know,
Marie Antoinette in the parties.
No, I get dressed
like a Mexican.
I say, I'm a Mexican princess.
I adore it, you
know, because I think
Mexico's a very strong country.
We have a lot of
controversial right now.
We need to work a lot.
I think we have a big potential.
I was very proud to see
that we are the 9 or the 11
economy of the world.
So let's make it Mexicans.
Let's do it.
Let's work every day and feel
proud of what we are doing.
SPEAKER: I think
you were talking
about being a princess who
wants to be a princess.
I think that you are
the queen now of--
MARTHA ORTIZ: Thank you.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: --everything.
Please join me in
thanking Martha.
[APPLAUSE]